يُظهر مقطع الفيديو الدعائي لحماس
مقاتليها وهم يخرجون من أنفاق تحت الأرض
فيما يبدو أنه
الضواحي الشمالية للمناطق الأكثر اكتظاظًا بالسكان
في غزة ويختبئون في التضاريس، ويطلق
جنود حماس النار على
الوحدات الإسرائيلية التي تتقدم إلى
غزة، ويُظهر مقطع فيديو جنديًا من حماس يطارد جنديًا
إسرائيليًا  ركضت دبابة
بجانبها ووضعت عبوة ناسفة على
الآلية ثم هربت بعد ثوانٍ، ففجرت
العبوة
مقاتل حماس ثم اختفت على الأرض
من خلال
مصيدة تحدث زعيم سياسي لحماس
هذا الأسبوع عن الدور الحيوي للنفق
في جيش حماس
في الوقت الذي شنت فيه إسرائيل
آلاف الغارات الجوية في جميع أنحاء غزة
منذ 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، تحاول حماس أيضًا
إظهار قدراتها في الضربات الجوية، فقد
أصدرت هذا الفيديو
لهجوم بذخيرة أسقطته طائرة بدون طيار على
جنود إسرائيليين، وليس من الواضح عدد
الإصابات التي ألحقتها بالجنود الإسرائيليين.
يمكن رؤية عدة جنود من قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية وهم
يهربون من الموقع،
وأصدرت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية هذا
الفيديو الدعائي لحماس والذي يصور متاهة
الأنفاق المتقنة التي
تمتد لعشرات الأميال تحت
غزة، وتستخدم المنظمة المسلحة
الأنفاق لتخزين الأسلحة وإطلاق
الطائرات  سبب الضربات تجاه إسرائيل هو أن
الصحفي الإسرائيلي المخضرم شوم إلدار
كان يكتب عن حماس منذ عقود، حيث
يقول إن الأنفاق تحت الأرض تُعرف
باسم مترو غزة، وهم يختبئون هناك، لقد
أنفقوا مليارات
الدولارات، وقاموا ببناء
منازل ومسار الأنفاق ومكانها، إنه
مشروع، إنه
مشروع ضخم.  إسرائيل تقول إن تفكيك
الأنفاق هو السبيل الوحيد لتفكيك
حماس في لافندريا CNN تل أبيب إسرائيل